hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
among the positions of the Stoics that
cicero discusses in his work the stoic
paradoxes one of the more
counterintuitive ones is that only the
wise are rich
we're often tempted to split these
things apart from each other and think
about being rich as one thing being wise
as another they could perhaps coincide
in people who we see as rich and we
think are very smart
you know people who've made a lot of
money recently but we also see you know
plenty of less intelligent people who
have inherited money or seem to have
fallen into it through one way or
another so this seems rather to go
against our experience right when we
talk about our experience of rich people
and what we understand based on on what
we see happening in the world so how
could it be that only the wise are rich
part of what cicero is doing in here is
really working out what it means to have
wealth and and what he's saying here a
lot of really great points to it you
know we have to ask well what does it
actually mean to be rich this is
something that many people including
lots and lots of people who handle money
for a living never really think of they
don't really work out for themselves and
so they're they're following their
desires that they're following ideas
that they inherited from say their
parents or the culture or the workplace
that they're in and the other people who
seem to be doing great and they don't
really ponder this what does it actually
mean to be rich Cicero says that it
means to have enough property to be
easily contented he says well this could
be relative you know do you have a
daughter well then you need to have a
dowry for her we don't do this quite so
much these days although there's still
the cultural habit of paying for a part
most of a wedding right for a daughter
but this this notion that
you know you need to have enough set
aside to deal with this daughter now if
you have two daughters well then you
have to have twice as much set aside
what if you had fifty like in the old
Greek Ledger well that would be a really
tough time now it all depends on what
you want to do with that money if you
think for example that setting aside
that money is really important because
what you need to do is have the wedding
of the century well you need a lot of
money for that don't you you have
another kid you'll need a lot of money
for that as well and and on and on and
on and Cicero says this can go very very
far when people don't rightly consider
what it is that they they actually need
to be contented you know if you for
example think that in order to really be
contented you need to have your own
private army well that's gonna cost a
hell of a lot of money and you know even
if we shrink it in what do you in fact
actually need do you need a certain size
of a house do you need to drive a new
car and buy a new car every other year
do you need to go on vacations do you
need to eat gourmet foods as opposed to
buying the generic brand which is
typically the same thing you know just
packaged differently we could go on and
on and on asking these sorts of
questions the key thing is what you need
in order to be contented Cicero was not
saying that you don't need anything but
he's saying that we can't actually be
contented fairly easily and he points
out that really this is something that
ought to be determined by ourselves as
he says by our own judgement not by the
judgement of our neighbors not by the
judgement of the culture out there that
is constantly bombarding us with
inflated and contradictory messages
about what we in fact need in order to
be living the good life or to be
contented or to think that we're doing
all right and we certainly don't want to
take our cues from other people
who are hyper-competitive about these
things or who are constantly on the make
constantly trying to acquire or those
who put us down we want to take our
guidance from ourselves we want to ask
ourselves what do I really need and if
we're honest with ourselves we actually
if our desires are correctly aligned we
don't need that much and if our desires
aren't rightly aligned perhaps that's a
sign that we ought to be doing that we
ought to be going through that now he
talks about those who we typically look
at as being rich and he says there's a
lot of wealthy people who still keep on
desiring more and more and more and more
the wealth that they have is not really
benefiting them because it's not
functioning as wealth that's something
to consider there's some really great
wisdom I mean he's talking about the
wives being rich here that's contained
in this the the things that we think
will make us happy or we'll be able to
buy us the things that make us happy if
we keep on desiring them after we have
them that's a sign that they're not
really satisfying that's a sign that
perhaps they're not even really goods so
what he says is these people are not
rich because they're not satisfied the
wise person who realizes that the
demands of the body are actually fairly
small and that what's required for us to
engage in our social interactions is
also similarly small if we trim away you
know worries about prestige and wearing
the the latest outfit or any of these
other sorts of things we don't you know
let people kow us into buying things we
don't need we we actually can live on
fairly little the rich quite often don't
do that yeah they may be that they
they're worried about what other rich
people think or what the the other
people who aren't rich who are you know
supposedly looking up to them think
Cicero says that these people actually
lack abundance they lack riches they
lack the very thing that they seem to
possess
and this is a very you know nice phrase
that it that he says here lacking
lacking abundance means lacking there's
this this you know flowing of wonderful
good things for us and and part of what
we have to do is be able to recognize
what actually is riches what are the
things that we need
perhaps it's books sometimes but we
don't even need that many books as
opposed to you know fine furnishings or
the latest technology now the last thing
that I want to say about this particular
paradox something that Cicero points out
that's really quite brilliant thrift is
an income what does he mean by that
thrift is an income if you can restrict
your spending if you're not buying more
than you need you are actually making
money in the process he gives you some
really great examples he says you know
for example this this this landlord over
there bring in six times what mine bring
in but he adorns his country houses with
gilt ceilings and marble floors and has
an unlimited covetousness for statues
pictures furniture and clothes so the
return is scanty not only for his
expenditure but even for the interest on
his debts it was possible to go deep
into debt back then whereas my narrow
income actually has something left over
and he says you know if we look at the
the examples of people in times past
they they show us that and he says those
people could be a guide in life then he
has some really great lines not to be
covetous is money not to be led by your
desires is to have wealth not to love
buying things is an income contentment
with one's own possessions is a very
large and perfectly secure fortune so
precisely by being wise we be
come rich and we end up possessing true
wealth